I get this question all the time they're
like how do I network with people who
are above me right it's a hard question
so number one is you don't ask them what
value can I provide you cuz now you're
asking me to do homework to figure out
what you can do for me that's me doing
work which I can just keep living my
life what you do is you do the hard work
of figuring out what can you provide to
me that you have and then instead of
offering it you do it and then give it
to me that's the game right like half
the editors I have they're like hey I
went through all of your old clips that
are on YouTube I clipped 20 of these
short reels this is what I did and they
sent them all to my creative director
and he was like oh this kid's good